asap rocky arrested in connection to a
los angeles shooting from 2021.
according to the lapd the rapper was
arrested on wednesday at lax upon his
return from barbados where he was
vacationing with his pregnant girlfriend
rihanna rocky was arrested for assault
with a deadly weapon stemming from an
incident that occurred the night of
november 6. according to police an
argument between two acquaintances
occurred in the hollywood area the
argument escalated and resulted in the
suspect firing a handgun at the victim
after the shooting the suspect and two
men fled the area officials say the
victim sought treatment for a minor
injury e.t has reached out to rocky's
lawyer for comment after rocky's arrest
on wednesday police officers were
spotted outside his los angeles home
at one point an officer leaves the
rapper's house carrying a cardboard box
full of what appears to be various items
and envelopes
the praise the lord rapper has been in
the news a lot lately as he gears up to
welcome his first child with rihanna
what are you enjoying about this journey
with fury right now everything about it
i'm loving it taking care of a girl
absolutely the couple started dating
before the covet 19 pandemic but became
serious during the lockdown and now
they're ready to start their lives
together as parents what are you looking
forward to as you move into a new
chapter of your life
i'm just excited for what i don't know
yet you know everything is new to me so
you know i'm excited
how are you keeping track of the
milestones as the two of you go through
this journey together
i mean i'm just living
[Music]
you